(bouncy, detective-style music)
- [Narrator] In the
peak of summer in Italy,
when the beaches and lakes
are full of swimmers,
the lifeguards keeping everyone safe
bring in some much needed assistance.
- [Narrator] Since then,
Ferruccio has found
that dogs make ideal lifeguard partners.
They remain calm under
pressure and instinctively
choose the safest path
through the water currents
back to shore.
Once in the water, they're
able to keep afloat
both the rescuer and the person in need.
- [Narrator] To keep
up with these numbers,
the school has over 350
certified rescue dogs,
and each year, takes in new recruits.
(man speaks in Italian)
After about 18 months of training,
they learn how to jump from speeding boats
and helicopters safely, among
other rescue techniques.
Italy is the only country in the world
that recognizes these certified canines
as actual lifeguards,
but the value of this
is catching on, so the school
is starting to expand abroad.
(dog barking)
(bouncy, upbeat music)
(chiming)